six changes that we intend to make and
the regulations giving effect to these
will
subject to parliament's approval take
effect on saturday
now i am aware that some of these
changes will sound technical and
relatively minor
however we believe that both
individually and collectively these
additional measures
and further reducing the interactions
that allow the virus to spread
will help our essential efforts to
suppress it and of course however
technical the changes might sound i know
that all of them
involve further restrictions on our
essential liberties so i want to give an
assurance again that none of these
decisions are arrived at
lightly let me therefore set out now
what these changes are
firstly we intend to limit the
availability and operation of click
and collect retail services only
retailers
selling essential items will be allowed
to offer click and collect this will
include for example clothes and food
wear
footwear baby equipment home wearing
books all other click and collect
services must stop more importantly
though for clicking collect services
that are allowed
staggered appointments will need to be
offered to avoid any potential for
queuing
and access inside premises for
collection it will not be permitted
the details will be set down in
regulations and in guidance i know that
businesses affected by this change will
be disappointed and that many
have gone to great lengths to make
services as safe as possible
but we must reduce as far as as possible
the reasons people
have right now for leaving home and
coming into contact with others
i welcome the actions of those
businesses that have voluntarily
suspended click and collect and
tighten their procedures in for example
relation to face coverings
secondly we intend to apply restrictions
to take away services
customers will no longer be permitted to
go inside to collect takeaway food or
coffee
any outlet wishing to offer take away
we'll have to do so from a serving hatch
or doorway
this is to reduce the risk of customers
coming into contact
indoors with each other or with staff
thirdly we intend to change the rules
around consumption of
alcohol at the moment different parts of
scotland have
different laws in relation to the
consumption of alcohol in outdoor public
places
however from saturday it will be against
the law in all level four areas
for uh to drink alcohol outdoors in
public
that will mean for example that buying a
takeaway pint and drinking it outdoors
will not be permitted
again i know this is not a popular move
but it is intended to underline and
support the fact that we should only be
leaving home right now for essential
purposes
that includes exercise or recreation but
it does not include simple socialising
and when you do leave home you should
only meet one person from another
household in a group
no bigger than two people i know this is
a hard message
and it is absolutely not one that i want
to be sending but it is vital to reduce
the risk of the virus
spreading fourthly and significantly we
intend
to strengthen the obligation on
employers to allow their staff to work
from home
whenever possible the law already says
that we should only be leaving home to
go to work if it is work that cannot be
done from home
this is a legal obligation that falls on
individuals however we will now
introduce statutory guidance to make
clear
to employers that they must support
their workers to work from home
wherever possible for all employers the
basic but vital message
is this if your staff were working from
home during the first lockdown last year
they should be working from home now and
you should be facilitating that
firstly we will strengthen the
provisions in relation to work inside
people's houses we've already issued
guidance to the effect that in level
four areas
work is only permitted within a private
dwelling if it is essential for the
upkeep maintenance and functioning of
the household
and we will now put this guidance into
law now the final change is an amendment
to the regulations requiring people to
stay at home
but i want to be clear this is intended
to close an apparent loophole
rather than change the spirit of the law
it will also
bring the wording of the state home
regulations in scotland into line with
the other uk nations right now the law
states that people can only leave home
for an essential purpose however having
left home for an essential purpose
someone could then stay out of their
home to do something that is not
essential
without breaching the law as it stands
so the amendment will make it clear that
people must not leave
or remain outside the home unless for an
essential purpose
this change will provide legal clarity
to facilitate any necessary enforcement
but i want to be clear that it doesn't
change the range of essential purposes
that currently
enable people to leave their house nor
does it for example put any time limit
on how long you can be outdoors for
essential
exercise but it does mean that if the
police challenge you for being out of
the house doing something that is not
essential
it will not be a defense to say that you
initially left to do something that was